[Musique]
allez aujourd'hui on parle de quoi
aujourd'hui on parle d'audio puisqu'on
parle de durance positionne ici dans le
temple de la musique avec tous les
artistes référence exceptionnel que je
vous conseille de venir écouter
voilà david je t'aime petit pensée pour
toi ouais on va se parler aux jeunes ce
produit là plantronics bac beats pro
5100 oui je suis en train de lire ce tic
est je le sais mais en fait comme je
peux vous dire de bêtises comme ça d'un
très long je le lis c'est beaucoup plus
simple donc on va se marier ce produit
là que plantronics m'a envoyé c'est une
vidéo aujourd'hui qui réalisé en
partenariat justement avec plantronics
pour venir vous présenter et vous parlez
de ce produit l'un pour la jeunesse
depuis quelques jours il est marqué sur
la boîte plantronics regarde d'abord par
ici et la marque vous verrez vous sur
votre boite et plantronics et polis
pourquoi parce que plantronics et
polycom ont fusionné et vous donne
police et une nouvelle marque c'est beau
c'est sympa s'appelle poli poli qui vous
propose donc ses backbeat regardez c'est
écrit noir sur blanc comme le port salut
j'ai menacé d expression peu 30 et c'est
toujours très rigolo mac beats pro 5100
ça c'est la boîte
là c'est le boîtier de charges et à
l'intérieur oppose un petit bouton
appuyer dessus vous avez vos écouteurs
[Musique]
regardez la botte l'aop les bugs mais
tous sortis directement
regardez-moi ça comme c'est tout mignon
normalement vous avez ça qui est mis là
avec vos boys à l'intérieur ça ça
fonctionne
vous y retrouvez vos différentes tailles
la small leur type vous avez l'âge ça va
vraiment dépendre de votre taille
d'oreille bon ça fonctionne
un sou de quoi le branchez vous avez
quelques petites informations dites
garantie et compagnie qui seront juste
là ça c'est cool je sais pas si vous
connaissez cette gamme là la gamme beats
de plantronics de police qu'il faut
parler maintenant de police cette gamme
met en avant la qualité audio une
collectivité fiable des technologies
innovantes du confort assassin petit peu
les promesses qui sont faites par la
marque là dessus et on alors justement
si ces promesses sont tenues
l'étude chargé aussi plutôt bien alors
ici vous allez pas bien l'ouvrir comme
ça vous avez un bouton vous appuyez il
s'ouvre en est de faire un peu d effet
rigolo quand vous voyez les écouteurs
tiennent quand même bien parce qu'ils
ont un petit aimant fait qu'ils viennent
les positionner à l'intérieur la
recharge et si au micro usb
voyez la connectique les deux aimants et
la connectique pour venir recharger les
écouteurs quant à eux sont plutôt bien
vous avez effectivement tout ce côté
tactile soit on tape soit en boutons
d'un côté comme de l'autre
là je suppose que ce sont vos petits
micros qui sont planqués
micro également de pouvoir je pense
retrouver également ici autre petit
capteur petit sensor qui est juste ici
qui vous permettra de capter ya six ans
sur vos oreilles oui ou non vos petits
en boubou d'éclipsé vous avez ça comme
ça ça vous change et très facilement
pour mettre les écouteurs à votre taille
on a donc ici des écouteurs trou
ailleurs laisse le couteur droit et
l'écouteur de gauche vont se connecter
indépendamment à votre device on
rayettes allumé niveau de la batterie et
ses pratiques merci beaucoup je la
prends je la tourne téléphones connectés
aux rêveries et donc là ça me dit
effectivement la même chose oreillettes
connectés niveau de la batterie et la
téléphones collectés
j'entends parler des deux côtés ces
pratiques au moins j'ai une information
vraiment docteur qu'est-ce que ça m'a
porté cette idée du travail en laisse
comme sa mise à part que la tâche serait
parce que tyson dans ma tête ça c'est
bizarre que les utiliser de façon
indépendante indépendante indépendamment
peu utilisé indépendamment de façon
indépendante
on met en place le français c'est
beaucoup plus simple comme ça donc je
peux passer un coup de fil avec juste
une oreillette si je souhaite tous les
cousins qui peu de musique
et puis rester ouverts sur le monde
parce qu'ici vous avez des notions de
bruit pas si ça veut donc dire que ça va
venir effectivement obstrué votre canal
c'est un attrape sa bien bloquer votre
canal ça et vite que le son extérieur
passe de façon trop importante ça vous
coûte un petit peu et ça fait son taf
alors moi je l'utilisé dans différentes
configurations j'étais en train jeudi
dans le métro est utilisé ici j'utilise
en marchant jeudi dans la rue rage
utilise un petit peu partout soif le
soir dans mon lit parce que sans
l'oreiller c'est tout un petit peu
inconfortable je vous le déconseille
mais pour le reste du temps c'est plutôt
pas mal et c'est assez confortable donc
vous pouvez utiliser à droite à gauche
le mieux c'est quand même les deux en
même temps ça c'est bien alors que
lorsque vous allez marcher dans la rue
passer un coup de fil avec les deux en
même temps ça vous coupe un petit peu du
goût et extérieur mais à côté de ça le
taf est plutôt bien fait l'an je vous
parle de la qualité audio est faux pas
de la qualité lors des appels dans
quelques instants à te parlait déjà en
tout cas ne serait ce que du côté
confort vous venez vous le positionner
confort et là lorsque vous avez trouvé
l'oreillette qui est à votre votre
oreille avait une bonne dimension
eh bien ça vient bloquer un petit peu
par une grande partie mon petit peu le
son extérieur donc on les isolations
passif qui fonctionne et ça ça fait le
taf donc ça c'est bien elles sont assez
confortables elles sortent un petit peu
quand même
alors ça c'est un c'est assez normal
c'est dans l'adn de ce produit là on les
voit on peut pas dire qu'on les voit pas
c'est pas gênant je trouve assez
résistante alcanes à éviter d'aller
pogoter vous jeter dans une foule
ce ne sont pas non plus des intra qui
sont faits pour aller faire du sport
vous avez une gamme fit chez plantronics
poli que vous allez pouvoir avoir
effectivement qu'ils seront mieux
adaptés
néanmoins sont des produits qui ne
craignent pas la transpiration qui ne
traînent pas de l'oci de plus un petit
peu une certification ipx4 donc
vraiment tranquille là dessus donc d'un
point de vue purement expérientiel je
les prends je les porte je suis bien ça
le contrat est rempli
ici en une techno qui s'appelle la
techno wind smart alors si vous parlez
pas anglais au wynn s'élevant ça va vous
aider un petit peut réduire le vent
l'idée c'est que vous avez quatre micro
antibruit qui vont venir capter le son
extérieur qui vont venir à nu et le son
pour éviter d'avoir trop de bruit
notamment lors des appels téléphoniques
ça fonctionne plutôt bien je vous
donnais une fois de plus mon rendu au
niveau de la qualité audio qui étaient
des appels dans quelques instants donc
je vous invite à patienter un tout petit
peu et puis tant qu'on parle justement
pensez à vous abonner s'est pas déjà cas
comme ça vous saurez tout sur la tête
les testent les produits à venir les
ciels et sa tac tac tac on y va on
s'abonne et ont mis la cloche ils ont
aussi un truc pas mal s'appelle le smart
sensor alors le smart sensor celles de
sap
c'est la voie qui part un petit peu en
hongrie le smart sensor c'est quoi c'est
en fait vous avez vos écouteurs comme ça
et lorsque vous allez venir retirer vos
écouteurs et bien mais elle aborde une
action qui va pouvoir être faite
normalement ce qui est paramétré par des
fautes dans l'application parce que oui
il ya une application et je vous la
montre dans quelques instants c'est
parce que vous prenez vos deux écouteurs
vous êtes en appel vous les enlevez en
même temps à venir
newt et le son ça va venir couper le son
vous pourrez dire autant de salles au
plus vous et sur vos interlocuteurs ils
ne seront jamais vous remettez ils nous
entendent ça va capter la présence de
votre oreille
ce sont des écouteurs qui ont du
bluetooth 3.0 une portée de 10 mètres
ils ont de la recharge en micro usb
ça c'est un peu bizarre d'avoir ces
choix là j'imagine que la connectique
côté probablement un peu moins cher
on n'est pas sur le standard usb sais
c'est pas très grave d'autant plus sa
surcharge assez rapidement en dix
minutes de chars vous obtenez une heure
d'autonomie donc vous êtes quand même
relativement peinard là-dessus pour une
charge complète des écouteurs il vous
faut deux heures et pour une charge
complète écouteurs plus et tu de
recharge il me faudra trois heures
autant plus que l'autonomie est vraiment
bonne là dessus plantronics aux annonces
6h30 d'autonomie par écouteurs en
musique et 4 heures en appels et 13
heures supplémentaires grâce au petit
boîtier de recharge radio vous les
prenez vous écouter et vous les mettez
dedans vous monté jusqu'à plus de 19
heures et en fait je trouve que la
promesse est plutôt bienvenu alors j'ai
paypal et 6h30 et kate mais j'ai les six
heures sans aucun problème donc je peux
aller très loin en terme de musique en
termes d coûte facilement donc ils sont
très très très peu énergivore
donc ça c'est vachement bien donc ça
c'est cool mais ça ne s'arrête pas
ça ne s'arrête pas là parce que vous
avez effectivement des petites commandes
des petits boutons tactiles directement
sur vos petits bugs à droite par défaut
je presse une fois plein je reprenne une
fois pause on m'appelle j'appuie je
décroche
j'en ai marre d'entendre personality
chez au téléphone j'appuie je raccroche
c'est relativement simple
j'appuie deux fois morceau suivant je
puis trois fois morceaux précédents jeux
fanapi dont deux secondes je vais soit
appelée google assistance et je suis sur
android et siri sur un os jusque là vous
me suivez
tandis qu'à gauche est bien là je vais
appuyer ça va monter le son je vais
appuyer un peu plus longtemps ça va
baisser le son c'est simple ça marche
c'est pratique c'est bien donc si je
monte sur plusieurs fois j'appuie
j'appuie j'ai depuis juin puis jacques
8s aussi je le bc leçon je prends les
appuyer sa baisse sauf façon dynamique
c'est simple c'est pratique c'est bien
et si j'en ai un petit peu marre je fais
un appui long de 4 secondes ça va venir
me les éteindre
à droite ou à gauche mais ça c'était
sans compter sur la partie my tapez vous
pouvez venir personnalisé dans votre
application on a une application qui est
juste ici qui s'appelle backbeat vous
prenez vous ouvrez ça vous affiche par
défaut lorsque vous arrivez le leur qui
vous restent sur les deux écouteurs bon
durée restante c'est plutôt bien
my tape pour il n'y a pas ce plaisir à
ma table ça c'est vachement cool soit
vous avez l'étape je dirais un petit peu
standard appui longs appuis courts vous
avez des raccourcis vous pouvez avoir
comme vous voulez bien pas de faire des
gestes
soit vous allez avoir la gestion du
volume le tap c'est vraiment le toucher
tactile c'est pas le bouton je vais
avoir un tape à gauche ça va monter le
volume
je vais avoir un tapez je vais laisser
appuyé longtemps ça va baisser le volume
ça c'est vraiment du tactile un joli hit
rap us c'est pas le bouton c'est pas
l'action mécanique soit boutons c'est
juste là dessus sur le petit sensor ça
sera soit ça comme à utiliser l'étape
comme ça pour une arrivée personnaliser
un appui statut de l'appareil deux
appuis syrie fait ce que vous voulez
pour venir complètement les paramétrer
il ya pas mal de possibilités
chacun fera ce qu'il voudra donc ce ne
soit plutôt bien pouvez-vous aller
jusqu'à d'ailleurs avoir bouclé disto
spotify playlist apple musique playlist
deezer ensuite vous venez ici la faute
petite molette dans vos paramètres et là
vous avez tous alors mise à jour de
l'appareil choisir votre langue jusque
là ça va bien mal tu as pris je vous ai
montré à l'instant que venir aussi
paramétrer directement ici
switch primary herbold vous pouvez venir
inversée dire que my table sera ici et
que la lecture pause sera de l'autre
côté le système du volume plus au plus
bas sans ça fonctionne voix hd voix hd
voix stand up conséquent même de mettre
voix
hd les smart sensor qui vous permettra
comme je vous le dis lorsque vous allez
retirer les deux est bien de mettre le
mode secret ça venir mouloud est en fait
le micro de votre appareil ou alors pour
aussi transférer la peine devant le
téléphone vous enlevez vos deux
écouteurs l'appel revient là dedans
battery mode affiché pour tâche de la
batterie affiché le temps votre
connexion là je suis connecté à mon
iphone ça se voit c'est bien s'il ya
d'autres appareils sont connectés
vous pouvez venir les retirer pour ne
garder que seul et que vous voulez le
guide utilisateur un assistant de
l'appareil les compacts si besoin de la
vidéo pour avoir quelques tutos ça je
trouve ça pas mal effectivement pour
revenir vraiment vous guide et vous
expliquer comment ça marche c'est cool
et réinitialiser ensuite tous les
réglages qui vous souhaitez le remettre
à zéro alors cette application je trouve
assez bien c'est intéressant le côté
mike capps et bien le fait de pouvoir
face au musée 2 3 trucs c'est bien mais
il manque un truc qui est vraiment
essentiel pour moi dans une application
qui est fait pour des buzz pour
l'audience le général c'est qu'il n'y a
pas des coins deezer vous ne pouvez pas
venir paramétrer l'audio ici vous ne
pouvez pas venir choisir le type de
qualité de vous voulez enfin c'est un
peu dommage parce que tu crois vraiment
que ça a un sens sur ce produit a dû se
dire ok effectivement ces petits bugs
sont bien peu vraiment venir les
optimiser grâce aux équaliseur
disponibles dans l'application et bien
il n'y a pas et ça pour moi c'est
vraiment dommage c'est vraiment un truc
que jour attendu là dessus qu'en est il
maintenant de la partie qualité audio
lorsque vous allez écouter de la musique
et passer des appels sous c'est quand
même fier et la fonction première de ces
bugs c'est effectivement de pouvoir en
profiter pour écouter du son de la
musique lorsque vous êtes en voyage en
déplacement chez vous voulez faites ce
que vous voulez comme vous voulez ça
vous regarde ça ne regarde pas et bien
c'est là où c'est un petit peu
surprenant parce qu'en fait je les
trouve pas mal globalement ils sont pas
mal l'expérience est plutôt positive
le toucher est bien l'autonomie et bol
le confort est bien et je trouve que
c'est dommage parce que la qualité audio
est un petit peu en dessous et ça peut
être un peu problématique non pas
qu'elle soit mauvaise mais qu'on
pourrait s'attendre à voir un peu plus
de finesse un peu plus de précision et
un peu plus de gouvy alors le groove et
sur un peu compliqué parce que le calme
soit des produits qui sont quand même
tout petit donc on peut pas s'attendre à
avoir des trucs qui sont complètement
révolutionnaire et qui vont vous secouer
les basses de ça paraît assez logique ça
c'est de la physique
néanmoins lorsque vous les prenez que
vous les mettez bien me positionner
vraiment des stars il est vraiment je
vais à gauche décidé aujourd'hui venais
vraiment à les positionner bien à fond
bien au fond vous allez récupérer un peu
de basses mais dès qu'elles vont bouger
un petit peu vous allez en parler un
petit peu
bon ça c'est pas extrêmement extrêmement
grave mais je trouve que de façon un
petit peu global le spectre nous paraît
un peu
et puis c'est pas la voir le spectre le
plus large doit pas aller chercher voyez
comme sur des cinq balles lorsque vous
écouter du jazz des cymbales ce que vous
et sont très précis et très fin le
spectre d'un redescendre pour se
rapprocher sont un peu plus médium et
c'est pareil au niveau des graves on va
avoir un son médium grave va pas voir un
saut qui va transmettre beaucoup trop
large et c'est un peu ce que je veux me
reprocher ses écouteurs poli entre onyx
pauli a fait un super boulot au niveau
de l'expérience yale sur ce produit mais
la fonction première des écouteurs ça
reste quand même la qualité audio n'est
pas encore ce que vous pouvez trouver à
la concurrence je trouve qu'il manque un
spectre un peu plus large
et ça c'est un petit peu dommage à côté
de ça la qualité des appels lorsque vous
allez passer un coup de fil dont la
russie et ça ça fait très très bien le
taf la qualité est au rendez vous alors
vous le dirai bien évidemment les appels
téléphoniques en général le spectre
kanev à ces médiums donc du coup les
écouteurs sont parfaitement le boulot à
ma connaissance on n'a pas non plus
d'appétit x a pété x hd là dessus bien
évidemment par réduction bruit active
mais ça c'est normal et on va pas du
tout leur reprocher je trouve qu'il leur
manque un petit quelque chose pour dire
ce produit il est vraiment là il leur
manque un petit chouya il faut vraiment
que poly bosse un peu plus sa copie au
niveau de la qualité audio globale pour
réussir à se dire ok mon produit les
tops il est vraiment top c'est un vrai
challenger pour tous les concurrents et
valeur terre extrêmement mal d'autant
plus que le prix il sort quand même à
179 euros 99 qui n'est pas non plus le
prix le plus agressif l'oreille à une
promesse moi je trouvais à 159 euros 99
ce qui est beaucoup mieux d'une façon un
peu général lorsque vous avez vos buzz
up les deux dans les oreilles je les
prends gelé mais c'est quand même
beaucoup mieux eh bien vous en enlever
un ça vous fait un truc tout bête et
tout con et qui mâche l'ambien taxe a
doublé la pause je vous en train de
regarder ça vous met la poste en votre
musique
donc ça c'est bien voilà un peu pour ces
backbeat pro 5102 poli dans l'ensemble
sont ça encourageant il ya eu un beau
travail de fait une belle proposition de
valeur il manque un petit quelque chose
au niveau l'expérience audio mais sauf
que on n'est pas en train de se dire il
manque un petit quelque chose au niveau
de la commande manque un petit quelque
chose sur la l'expérience audio et c'est
ce qu'on va rechercher en premier sur un
produit comme celui là sont les
écouteurs premier dans les oreilles on
de l'audio c'est un peu dommage malgré
tout sont quand même relativement bien
donc s'il vous intéresse vous pouvez y
aller ailleurs si vous intéresse j'ai
mis des liens en bas d'un description
vous de me dire si vous connaissez ce
produit si vous l'avez déjà utilisé
peut-être pas sous la marque polito
plantronics mcbee
pro 5100 ce qui pourrait vous tentez
vous remarquez tout ça en bas on
commence à nous on se retrouve demain et
on continue à parler tech avec le labour
à demain
[Musique]